this is a standard ass paperclip there
are no bells and whistles on this
paperclip [ __ ]
I've traded when I was in like middle
school I think I can get to a house in a
week why not let's go
you don't use bartering in our everyday
society I walk up to these two nice
gentlemen and I offered them the
paperclip and they gave me a nice
postcard which I thought was a fair and
equal trade Devon traded her paperclip
for a postcard and I ended up going up
to those same guys and trading my
paperclip for a bigger paper slip I went
into this being really realistic I was
like hey it's a paperclip so let's give
me something comparable whereas I feel
like Alaska kind of went into it being
like what's the best thing I could get a
sticker it was like two kids that were
like going to school or coming back from
school or something hell yeah who would
you be down to trade for paper good hell
yeah next logical step was to try to see
if I could get like some kind of a gift
card so I went up to this one guy do you
have like a froyo gift card my plan was
gonna get a little sticky he tried to
trade me a postcard for his hotel room
key lesson learned there are weird
people in Hollywood then I found another
guy on the street I knowingly traded my
postcard for a gift card that I knew was
only worth 26 cents you have something
of value I could trade it for so I met
this rapper traded him the heli a
sticker for two dollars yeah dude yeah a
couple bucks who work I was wondering if
I could trade for well your knife I
offered her the gift card and instead of
the knife she gave me her wooden spoon
with like her name tattooed to the edge
of it which I thought was super cool
Devon spoon was cool I'll give her that
but it's no match to what I have I put
up an ad on Craigslist to see who would
bite the answer is nobody in Los Angeles
wants to trade for a wooden spoon it's
harder than I thought to continue to
trade up as you get bigger and bigger
things I have not felt this rejected
since 11th grade when I had to ask
someone else to prom I think I'm doing
really well in the competition I ended
up trading this
hello I was able to turn two dollars
into five dollars for my five dollars I
traded this unopened portable charging
device I'm not gonna stop here I'm gonna
keep going
oh it's victory the beginning of this I
was like way overly competitive and just
wanted to like crush Devon people look
at their lives and assess what they're
willing to give up and the answer is
very little motivation is at an all-time
low how the [ __ ] am I supposed to trade
for this [ __ ] now I'm considering like
what do people have on their person that
is worth like ten to fifteen dollars
that they want to trade for this thing
after seeing how hard all this is I'm
like being Devon are kind of in this
together let's just see what cool things
we can come up with together every
single human has a phone we ended up
combining our items and trading them for
an experience that we both wanted to do
yeah the guys selling these Hollywood
tours are like always out there that
colleague ritorto hustled the hustlers
yeah
Oh shoes you guys should go anytime you
want you get your pride I've actually
lived here for five years and I've never
gone on a Hollywood tour yes either way
it's crazy to me that we had derived
from a paper clip yeah came from one to
two paper clips paper clips are things
you throw away and like we turned it
into this like over $80.00 experience
that people come to Hollywood to do like
that's truly remarkable Mike how much is
this worth $79 Alaska and I already made
plans to go this weekend yes the
takeaway for me from this whole
experience I guess money is just a
representation of like what where we put
value and I realized that we actually
put like too much value on just like the
paper bills I would say friendship is
the real prize
it was friendship was the real prize